I used to steal from Walmart I treated
that place like a personal ATM right by
the best count I probably stole 57 flat
screen TVs you know 100 or more [__]
electric toothbrushes I mean do we used
to go in and take those electric razors
that cost like 100 200 or electric
toothbrushes and I would get like one of
each or a couple of them and and I would
have like a Walmart bag and I would just
put them in the bag and I would walk to
the return desk and return them and get
gift cards and then sell the gift cards
for 50 cents on the dollar it was like
ding ding ding it was like 15 minutes
I'd have the guy that was buying the
gift cards in the [__] parking lot
waiting for me go up in the gift card he
has 300 give me a buck 50 pull them out
it was crazy